[Musik]
die demokratie stirbt die politik
erreicht die menschen nicht mehr und die
pandemie legt die probleme gnadenlos
offen das sagt der neubau bei mir
sie sind bürgermeister von augustusburg
in sachsen
sie sagen die demokratie stirbt sind sie
sicher wenn wir so weiter machen bin ich
mir relativ sicher dass das passiert ja
also ich glaube das wird tatsächlich in
diesem land dann im punkt angekommen
sind wir wahrscheinlich alles anders
machen müssen
sie haben sehr eigene erfahrung mit der
pandemie gemacht deswegen weil sie in
augustusburg auch ein experiment gemacht
haben und sie haben da auch sehr viel
gelernt nicht nur über die pandemie
sondern auch über das funktionieren oder
nicht funktionieren von politischen
strukturen
das war so ein bisschen ein experiment
ein modellfall wie in tübingen
sie haben gesagt wir wollen hier etwas
machen was die menschen sicherer macht
ein pandemie zurückdrängt wie sah das
aus man muss ja sehen was was in diesen
in diesem jahr pandemie mit gesellschaft
passiert auch gerade in so einer kleinen
stadt
ich habe wahnsinnig viel mit leuten zu
tun die wirklich mit inzwischen mutlos
sind und dann haben wir uns auf den weg
gemacht haben gesagt wir müssen jetzt
müssen einfach mal versuchen eine
alternative zu diesem ständigen
schließen zu finden das war der auslöser
dann habe ich leute gefunden die da sehr
hoch motiviert mitarbeiten aus dem
wirklich hightech-bereich die da auch
lust auf hatten und wir haben dann
einfach ein projekt heraus gemacht und
haben dann monate braucht erstmal die
landesregierung davon zu überzeugen dass
das eine coole idee wäre
und tatsächlich ob bis wenige stunden
vorher nicht mehr gewusst ob das
tatsächlich machen dürfen also es war
wirklich alles ziemlich nervig
anstrengend und dann haben wir es
gemacht und haben gezeigt dass es geht
aber wie sie das genau aus ich habe
jetzt gerade gesagt es ist eigentlich so
ein modellfall wie in tübingen gewesen
etwas ein bisschen anders also sagen sie
mal wie anders ja also wir haben die
grundlage ist quasi ein ganz einfaches
digitales system das
muss ja einfach sein neues bedienen
können wir nehmen das einfachste mittel
die gmail sozusagen das heißt sie gehen
auf die stadt webseite stadt
augustusburg registrieren sich dort
bekommen dann per e mail einen qr-code
in können sie sich im telefon in ihrer
rolle packen dann haben sie es wie so
ein flugticket abgespeichert und mit
diesem qr-code gegen die sozusagen alles
das heißt sie gehen ins zentrum zeigen
den qr-code vor ort abklären test wird
eingescannt abstrich gehen sind sie
immer minute durch gewesen kriegen dann
später per e mail das ergebnis dass dies
auch verwenden können für den friseur
wie auch immer aber der qr code den sie
haben wurde dann automatisch immer für
24 stunden zur eintrittskarte und in
jedem gastronomischen einrichtung jedem
hotel alles was was mit gemacht hat
wurde am eingang zusammen per scan
gecheckt grün oder rot also gibt's
ungültigen test ist alles gut und konnte
rein und wenn ich muss da draußen wie
erfolgreich war dass es war sehr
erfolgreich wir haben 16.000 test
gemacht und drei wochen davon waren
knapp 10.000 tests besucher oder stadt
wir sind ein sehr touristisch angebunden
außen sofern für uns sehr wichtig dass
das wieder losging und es hat
unglaublich was bewegt in den menschen
also ich habe eine unglaubliche freude
wieder wahrnehmen dürfen wir haben
gelernt dass menschen wahnsinnig achtsam
miteinander umgehen können werden dieses
projekt ist also wenn sich irgendwo eine
warteschlange gebildet hat konnte man
die zwei meter die sich automatisch
gebildet haben sozusagen quasi
nachmessen also mussten nicht nach
steuern es gab keine verstöße die leute
war unglücklich weil sie wie erwachsene
menschen behandelt worden sind und dann
funktioniert das auch dann ist aber was
passiert da kommt eine bundes notbremse
und dann haben sie gesagt moment wenn
ich das jetzt nicht mehr machen darf
dann ziehe ich auch persönlich
konsequenzen sie sind parteilos
gestartet 2013 bürgermeister dann haben
sie gesagt ja ich gehe in die spd ich
brauch parteien unterstützung da
sprechen wir später noch drüber und bei
der bundesweiten sagen sie sagt jetzt
reicht's mehr
warum ja das war der letzte punkt also
ich habe sehr viel zeit damit verbracht
auf landesebene zu versuchen dem zu
platzieren die aus kommunaler sicht
wichtig sind also wir haben da schon
mittlerweile glaube ich eine ziemlich
große klaffende lücke zwischen zwischen
der basis ebene da wo menschen
tatsächlich wohnen und und sozusagen
alles wirkt was irgendwo beschlossen
wird und und diesem ort wo beschlossen
wird das ist schon zum land ziemlich
weit weg
der bund ist ist der mond und europa ist
pluto also für die leute und ja das
haben wir eben an dieser stelle zu
spüren bekommen das projekt das mit mit
abgewickelt wurden obwohl wir zu dem
zeitpunkt glaube ich das einzige
deutschland war was auch mit einer
universität hintendran tatsächlich
wissenschaftlich gearbeitet hat weil
darum ging es ging uns nicht darum dass
wir ein paar wochen vor dem rest der
welt ein bisschen feiern können
sondern es ging darum daten zu sammeln
um gerüstet zu sein für keine ahnung die
nächsten herbst weil wenn wir so
weitermachen wie wir jetzt gerade mit
impfen und testen und allen möglichen
weitermachen kann es ja durchaus sein
dass der nächste herbst genauso wird wie
der letzte
und dafür wollen wir gerüstet sein weil
ich mich im letzten sommer schon selber
mit fragen musste am ende dieses sommers
als dieser herbst lockt dann kam ich
mich ja auch fragen lassen musste was
habt ihr denn den sommer über gemacht
und das zu verhindern
sie haben geschrieben von einer
überbordenden bürokratie und haben auch
geschrieben ja das sei ja schon fast
autokratisch was da passieren würde in
deutschland ist das nicht ein bisschen
überzogen autokratie ist ja so weit von
na ja so formen von totalitarismus von
diktatur gar nicht entfernt
na ja wieder war dass er mal so einen
kraftausdruck naja man muss da schon man
muss ja schon klare sätze sprechen das
ist ja das was ich was ich in der
politik hauptsächlich vermisse
hauptsätze zu verwenden und eine klare
aussage zu machen ich habe auch
geschrieben dass ich nicht behaupten
dass ich recht habe
aber was wo ich mir relativ sicher wenn
es das wird überreden müssen und wir
haben tatsächlich inzwischen die
situation dass die kommunen mehr und
mehr gerade kleinere kommunen im
ländlichen raum bei den großen städten
ist es noch ein bisschen anders aber wir
als kreisangehörigen städte sind im
wesentlichen inzwischen so was wie auch
philips gehilfen das heißt es wird
verkündet und wir setzen um viele
unserer probleme müssen wir wirklich
durch die in tanz instanzen schleppen
inzwischen
um irgendwo mal zu einer lösung zu
kommen die finanzielle ausstattung der
kommunen ist desaströs nach wie vor
es wird immer über die wird immer
geredet gerade bei uns in sachsen gibt
es dieses beflügelt wird er kommen ein
familie und in unserer verfassung steht
die die das recht auf selbstverwaltung
aber am ende des tages haben wir gar
nicht wer die möglichkeiten und wenn wir
wollen dass menschen die sich ja mehr
und mehr vom politischen system abkehren
und das können wir deutlich sehen das
ist ja keine erfindung von hannover wenn
wir wollen dass die begreifen was
demokratie an wert ist müssen sich das
in der kommune erlebbar machen dort wo
man sich einmischen kann dort wo der weg
kurz ist wo man wo man wirklich noch
sein würden erleben kann wenn wir dort
nicht die möglichkeiten schaffen wenn
wir die kommunen nicht soweit stärken
dass das wieder geht wenn wir nicht in
den kommunen wieder entscheidend lassen
was die menschen wirklich direkt
betrifft direkt vor ort dann dann werden
die menschen und nicht nur gerade dann
ist ja das was jetzt hdmi passiert ist
genau gegenläufig dann ist das was wir
jetzt erleben
mit einer entscheidung auf der
bundesebene für alle kommunen quasi für
alle bürger genau das gegenteil von dem
was sie sagen was notwendig ist und
politik wieder für den bürgern aber zu
machen und erlebbar zu machen
sie haben ein sehr schönes beispiel das
würde ich gerne noch mal von ihnen hören
im buch beziehungsweise in einem
interview mal genannt da gibt es
wanderwege bei ihnen und da gibt es
nachvollziehbare weise ihren wunsch in
dem augenblick wo sie sagen mit diese
wanderwege das sind noch die alten
schilder aus der ddr ich möchte jetzt
mal neue schilder hier haben dann haben
sie das mit unterstützung gemacht was
daraus geworden
also wir haben es jetzt im ziel das ist
daraus geworden das hat dass das hat
funktioniert aber der weg war natürlich
wir jetzt meistens ist es wahnsinnig
kompliziert haben in dem fall mit
europäischen fördergeldern tiert was
sehr viel besser ist als sein ruf also
dieses system ist zwar sehr kompliziert
aber es ist planbar
das unterscheidet das von von der firma
lotterie die man normalerweise im land
haben wo es darum geht wer ist der
schnellste oder wer hat einfach glück
oder wer kennt den richtigen wir immer
dort ist es plan war aber es ist halt
fanden sich aufwändig in verden hat das
problem bei einem wanderweg der läuft
ein stück über die gemarkung der stadt
kämen
so und es waren vier masten also viel
holz massen die dahin mussten und die
stadt chemnitz ist aus diesen leader
förderprogramm so heißt das europäische
förderprogramm nicht förderfähig
weißenstadt ist mit mehr als 5000
einwohnern
das heißt es war ein schlag durch diese
vier masten nicht förderfähig weil sie
quasi im acker oder stadt chemnitz
stecken
und wir haben dann am ende diese vier
dinger tatsächlich selber bezahlt weil
zwar der förderzweck war diesen weg zu
beschwören und hätten wir die
weggelassen wir haben wahrscheinlich
unsere gäste irgendwann im outback
verdurstet aber fakt ist wir haben es
dann wir haben es dann klären müssen
weil es eben nicht so wie ich ist
sondern und da frage ich mich dann dass
es im moment gerade mit den
prüfungsaufwand ich auf die prüfung im
nachgang hat über anderthalb jahre
gedauert
inklusive eines prüfer wechsel ist wo
dann alles noch mal neu losgehen sollte
und wenn man das mal aus rechnet für
eine gesamtsumme von ich glaube 30.000
euro haben wir nochmal ein prüfaufwand
der ging also auch noch mal irgendwie um
15 20 euro man das mal wirklich
ausrechnen würde da müssen wir uns schon
fragen ob das sinn macht und das war ein
wanderweg ja das waren wanderwege
sie haben gesagt dass eine touristische
gegend da kommen viele besucher hin der
ja auch für oder eine solche aktion ist
ja auch für sie wichtig in augustusburg
wenn wir jetzt komplexen dingen kommen
zb ihrem experiment ihrem beispiel in
der pandemie dann ist das ja kaum noch
zu bewältigen in der bürokratie
wir haben einen punkt erreicht dass wir
alles so organisiert haben und so
geregelt haben dass wir in solchen
komplexen situationen ist der
idealzustand ist mein eindruck
inzwischen dass stillstand
also am besten wir tun dann gar nichts
mehr weil damit keine angst dann kann
nichts mehr schief gehen die man muss
eine komfortzone verlassen niemand was
muss das entscheiden muss vielleicht
auch ein risiko gehen das machen wir
alles nicht mehr
das ist auch ein
gesamtgesellschaftliches problem das hat
nicht nur mit politik zu tun das hat
auch was damit zu tun dass wir eine
gesellschaft auch keine fehler toleranz
mehr haben
stellen sie sich mal folgende situation
vor allem politiker würde hantieren wie
ein erfolgreicher manager bei google
beispielsweise und bei google sagt
werden wir springen 10 10 projekte an
den start von denen wir glauben da
könnte energie drin sein und zwei ins
ziel und acht scheitern
das ist für google eine riesen quote in
der politik wäre das sichere untergang
so also das hat auch was wiederum auch
mit uns als bürger zu tun dass wir das
wir politikern natürlich tatsächlich
auch keine fehler verzeihen weil wir
immer eine diskussion führen und am ende
wissen müssen wir es denn eigentlich
schuld also wir lösen ja nie probleme
strukturell wir hören wir dann auch wenn
wir wissen dass irgendjemand schuld war
und den können wir dann hinrichten und
dann ist das thema erledigt und so
kommen wir nicht mehr weiter also das
ist so das ist unsinn misstrauens system
geworden inzwischen dass der bund den
ländern nicht die länder den kommunen
nicht wir kommunen trauen dem land
inzwischen nicht mehr über den weg und
dann erwarten wir aber dass der bürger
uns traut dann darf aber nicht was böses
passieren wir diese pandemie denn die
hat ja nun ganz offenbar gezeigt dass
wir an ganz vielen stellen keine
wirklich gute struktur mehr haben und
auch keine fähigkeit mehr haben sehr
schnell dinge umzusetzen
als sie das gefühl hatten ich brauche
die unterstützung einer partei und in
die spd eingetreten sind was haben sie
denn auf der ebene dieser sagen wir mal
kommunalpolitik im sinne von einer
partei politik erlebt war das effizient
also man muss ja sagen das ist jetzt
meine ganz persönliche einschätzung aus
dem was sich bei uns sehe parteipolitik
findet in den unteren ebenen fast nicht
mehr statt
das ist der erste fehler und das ist
tatsächlich ja inzwischen auch ein
akzeptierter zustand weil sätze wie
parteipolitik spielt in der kommune
keine rolle sind inzwischen setze die
können sie innerhalb einer partei
ungestraft aussprechen und eigentlich
verkünden wir dort ja schon den beginn
das problem ist weil wir da nämlich
aufzeigen das ist diese diese lücke gibt
zwischen dem politischen orbit und dem
dem da und so zu sagen und ich sag dann
immer also parteipolitik sollte nicht
nur auf einer kommunalen ebene nicht
unbedingt die vorderste geige spielen
sondern vielleicht auch dort wohl wo die
wichtigen entscheidungen getroffen
werden da sollte es ja auch um die sache
eigentlich gehen das ist die botschaft
die da immer sofort ab drin stecken soll
aber eigentlich ist es nur das
eingeständnis dass die basis im
wesentlichen abhanden gekommen ist und
das ist im osten tatsächlich ein
ernsthaftes problem weil wenn wir uns
mal die gesamtpartei mitgliedschaft
ansehen dann ist der osten sehr sehr
deutlich unterrepräsentiert
und das sagt ja was sagt uns ja was das
ist ja das ist ja eine aussage die eine
bevölkerung eines landstrichs gegenüber
einem system sagt und das hat mich
historie also der osten ist da
sicherlich auch ich sag mal etwas
gebrannt
was parteien erfahrung betrifft aber das
sagt etwas aus über die letzten 30 jahre
und da haben wir viel falsch gemacht und
wir haben viele leute rechts und links
stehen lassen und die fehlen uns jetzt
und da ist das vertrauen nicht da und da
müssen wir anfangen weil ansonsten wird
uns werden uns weiter teile der
bevölkerung auf handelt wenn sie jetzt
gerade über diese besondere
befindlichkeit wie man das so schön sagt
der ostdeutschen sprechen und sagen das
hat etwas damit zu tun dass ich da viele
abwenden
dann wenden dieses jahr 22 einer partei
wie der afg zu warum tun die da sind wir
überzeugt von den inhalten der partei
teils teils also ja es gibt natürlich
menschen die überzeugt davon sind dass
die diese so genannte alternative
wirklich eine ist
ich glaube ja inzwischen nicht mal mehr
dass eine partei ist für mich ist das
tatsächlich ein sammelbecken wirklich
reines protest sammelbecken das sieht
man auch sie eigentlich sehr schön weil
also eine tatsächliche tatsächliche
arbeit findet dort braucht nicht
wirklich statt das einsammeln von unmut
aber das ist ein das ist aber ein unmut
den sie ja begründen können den haben
sie ja gerade geschildert und
nachvollziehbar es ist absolut
nachvollziehbar ich denke wir haben 10
15 prozent werden das vielleicht in
sachsen seien die wirklich
kernwählerschaft sind und wir sehen das
immer gesehen bei der bürgermeisterwahl
im oktober letzten jahres dadurch schon
auf die gegenkandidaten der zehn prozent
bekommen
bei bundestags- oder europawahl wird
auch meine stadt 29 30 prozent fd und
dieses gap diese 20 prozent das sind die
um die wir uns kümmern müssen und
kümmern ist da schon wieder das falsche
wort die wir ansprechen müssen das ist
vielleicht sogar wichtiger die wir
aktivieren müssen die wir mit einbinden
müssen was wir aber machen ist ist das
was man immer machen ja keine lösung hat
man stigmatisiert sortiert und grenzt
aus und menschen die sich ausgegrenzt
fühlen denn ich sage jetzt ganz bewusst
fühlen klammer auf ob das
richtig ist oder nicht klar dazu ist
erst mal zweiter aber sie fühlen sich
ausgegrenzt
die kann ich nicht einbinden in den ich
sie aus grenze und das ist der große
fehler den wir glaube ich im osten
machen mit den ganzen gesprächs verboten
die da verhangen sind mit denen redet
man nicht mit den kammern nicht reden
und und somit rechten nicht reden das
sind nicht alles rechte
wir müssen wieder anfangen zu
differenzieren und genauer hinzusehen
wer ist da eigentlich mit welchen
problemen und das ist anstrengend und
das geht aber tatsächlich auch fast nur
auf der kommunalen ebene und dazu müsste
aber erst mit dieser ganze apparat
überfluss aber findet da etwas ähnliches
statt wenn sie das so beschreiben als
sammelbecken derjenigen die ideologisch
möglicherweise unterwegs sind diejenigen
die unter dem gefühl protest unterwegs
sind und möglicherweise leuten die sagen
ja das andere gefällt mir eben nicht ich
such mal quasi eine alternative ist das
eine ähnliche situation wie wir sie
erleben bei demonstrationen gegen die
pandemie maßnahmen bei denen wir ja auch
kaum mehr feststellen können wer gehört
jetzt zu wem das ist ein konglomerat von
verschiedensten strömungen
das ist der kleinste gemeinsame nenner
ist ist es das gefühl dass in diesem
land irgendwas nicht so läuft und da
sind verschiedene trends im gange das
zum einen natürlich wirklich glaube ich
ein versagen des politischen systems zu
sehen dass da viel vertrauen verloren
gegangen ist auch der kontakt verloren
gegangen ist da spielen auch andere
trends mit rein wir leben in einer zeit
wo dass das individuum ganz vorn steht
vor jeder er glaubt dass er sozusagen
der mittelpunkt der welt ist das ist
natürlich sind megatrend der ist da aber
darauf muss man ja in europa form
reagieren und das tun wir nicht
also wir machen immer so weiter diese
dieses dieses parteiensystem ist toll
die repräsentative demokratie ist toll
ich wüsste keine alternative aber sie
wirkt gerade momentan sowie wie sie
hantiert wie ein fremdkörper in einer
unglaublich dynamisierten zeit wenn wir
die nächsten letzten 15 jahre nehmen
unsere leben hat sich dramatisch
verändert wie wir miteinander umgehen
wie wir arbeiten wie wir zur
meinungsbildung kommen wie wir
miteinander kommunizieren
andere wertevorstellungen die nächsten
generationen die mit völlig anderen
wirklich völlig anderen vorstellungen
unterwegs sind als wir noch
das sind riesige spannungsbereich die da
bin ganz kurzer zeit entstanden sind und
daneben steht dieser parteien apparat
wie kann es denn sein dass das letztlich
bewegungen wie freies for future bis
heute eigentlich kennen keinen
wirklichen politischen schnittpunkt
gefunden haben
den gibt es immer noch nicht obwohl das
thema was sie in dieser bewegung ja
behandelt wirklich ein existenzielles
ist und mir wird angst wenn ich mir
überlege was was die pandemie die ja was
er noch relativ gut zu managen war im
gegensatz zum klimawandel beispielsweise
mir wird immer angst wenn ich mir
vorstelle dass wir jetzt in dieser phase
kommen mit dieser zerrütteten
gesellschaft den klimawandel zu
verhandeln der dann wirklich mit mit mit
harten einschnitten verbunden sein wird
wir sind darauf ganz schlecht
vorbereitet wir sind gut beraten wenn
wir jetzt mal eine stop taste drücken
und uns mal selber hinterfragen und
fragen ob das alles noch so in der
pandemie merken wir wie aggressiv
menschen werden können sie haben das von
der stimmungslage jetzt beschrieben
das ist aber auch sehr persönlich das
heißt sie haben ja selber auch an
verhandlungen erlebt sie erleben dass
kommunalpolitiker nicht mehr antreten
weil sie sagen dass es mir einfach zu
gefährlich geworden
das gibt es ja das ist auch nicht schön
ich habe da noch einen anderen sagen wer
sich in gefahr begibt der muss das dann
eben auch hinnimmt bis zu einem gewissen
maß glaube ich tatsächlich dass unsere
aufgabe ist sich dorthin zu stellen und
das auch mal einzufangen
aber wie weit geht das denn bei ihnen
wie weit würden sie dann akzeptieren
dass man gegen kommunismus hat mit kran
vorgeht im sinne von ich schreibe ihnen
auch mal an ich schreib dem malen bösen
brief aber da geht es ja viel viel
weiter
ja also ich hab ich persönlich hatte
auch beim liegen dass auch tatsächlich
bis zur schriftlichen motto briefkasten
das gab es alles
das war auch ein punkt wo man
tatsächlich auch wirklich kurz die luft
weg jetzt weiter
ich habe entschieden dass es mit mir
nichts macht bleibt weiterhin im
gespräch ich habe eine ganz einfache
regel
ich versuche mit jedem egal wo er steht
und wer herkommt erstmal ins gespräch zu
kommen und jeder der in der lage ist ein
halbwegs vernünftigen diskurs auf die
beine zu stellen ist dazu herzlich
willkommen
wenn diese regeln verletzt werden wenn
grenzen überschritten werden
der höflichkeit oder schlimmeres dann
ist auch bei mir schluss aber ich habe
zumindest erstmal ein angebot gemacht
und das ist ein wichtiges argument ich
habe das in vielen langen gesprächsfäden
mit mit auch mit bürgern die die
teilweise auch wirklich zu recht wütend
sind dass das langfristig auch wirklich
funktionieren kann also dass man
zumindest im gespräch bleibt sie sind
beim wahlkampf von tür zu tür gegangen
das ist jetzt noch nichts besonderes
aber sie wollten sich eigentlich
vorstellen aber sie haben ja eigentlich
einen riesen korb an problemen
schwierigkeiten sorgen mitgeteilt
bekommen das hatten sie glaube ich nicht
erwartet das war 2013 im ersten
wahlkampf das stimmt tatsächlich ich bin
also losgegangen und habe mich kennt ja
hier niemand etwas dazu sage ich stamme
nicht aus der stadt in der ich jetzt
bürgermeister bin das ist in kleineren
städten eigentlich ein absolutes no-go
wenn man sich um so ein amt bewirbt
deshalb bin ich rausgegangen und habe
versucht das gespräch zu führen
und eigentlich zu vermitteln wer ich bin
und was ich so für ideen habe aber dazu
kam es eigentlich gar nicht weiß einen
gigantischen gesprächsstoff gab also
überall dort wo ich ins gespräch kam war
ich nicht der der sender sondern
eigentlich der empfänger und ich gemerkt
habe dass keine transparenz da war die
menschen und ich wusste was sind ihre
stadt teilweise los ist wo wir stehen
was es für eine entwicklungs idee gibt
also wir haben dass das ist für mich war
das momentum wo ich begriffen habe dass
da generell was schiefgeht weil die
kleine politik lernt von der großen das
ist so
und diese mangelnde transparenz diese
entschuldigung streckenweise hybris die
man in sich trägt wenn sie sätze gesagt
wie ich weiß was meine bürger wollen ja
dass solche sätze kennt man kenne ich
aus der landespolitik sehr viel also ich
habe ein schönes beispiel telefonat mit
dem mit einem mit einem ministerium wo
dann wo dann
was vorgetragen ob was wir machen
wollten was ist jetzt eigentlich total
geil war es geht ums prinzip und die die
gegenseite dann sagt das will der
freistaat nicht und ich dann sage dann
haben wir ein problem dann ist der
freistaat ist als kreativ gestört weil
ich bin auch freistaat und wir wollen
das ja so und das meine ich und wir
versuchen das rum zu drehen und ich sage
den leuten immer es ist eure stadt das
ist euer geld du bist die stadt ich bin
die stadtverwaltung und wenn du sagst
die stadt muss was machen weinst du auch
dich das ist ein langer weg wir haben
aber gott sei dank immer noch sehr viele
sich wahnsinnig dankbar unglaublich
viele leute die sich engagiert und es
werden auch wieder mehr und ich habe
auch mittlerweile das gefühl dass die
menschen schon bereit wären sich mehr
einzubringen sich auch mehr in die
verantwortung zu begeben wenn wir sie
denn endlich ließen aber wenn wenn
jemand mit zu ihnen kommt und hat ein
tolles projekt dann kommt er einmal und
dann kommt da zwei mal kommt er doch ein
drittes mal
und das ist genau das was ich meine ist
fängt tatsächlich bei bei einem
wichtigen punkt an der dann immer an der
landespolitik gerne so abgetan wurden
nämlich beim gates natürlich brauche ich
wenn ich wenn ich wir haben zum beispiel
so ein format entwickelt die doro
projekte das heißt ich bin
augustusburger ich habe eine idee ich
habe fünf leute mit dem ich das machen
das ist das was ich leiste das ist das
was ich von der stadt als unterstützung
braucht und ich habe noch mindestens 40
augustusburg gefunden die sagen ja das
ist wirklich relevant was ihr da macht
dann haben wir 50.000 euro gehabt im
haushalt und haben die dann verteilt auf
einem jahr so 10 15 projekte wir haben
ungefähr 30 projekt jetzt umgesetzt
danach mussten wir stoppen weil das geld
nicht mehr haben und das ist schade weil
wir haben gesehen was da passierte
stellen sie sich vor in der
durchschnittliche stadtratssitzung in
einer stadt wie unsere auf dem land 4512
einwohner es gibt kein aufreger thema
weil wir gerade kinder straßen bauen
oder irgendwas weil wir dafür und ich
wirklich geld da kommen im jahr
vielleicht 15 leute die damals zu hören
oder vielleicht meine frage haben wenn
sie über bürgerprojekte entscheiden
sitzen 60 leute im saal weil die alle
sehen wollen wie entscheidet der
stadtrat jetzt die haben alle noch mal
die möglichkeit ihre projektidee
vorzustellen da ist energie da finden
leute zusammen da kommen leute hinterher
zu mir und sagen das war bisher nur
wusste ich dass der drei häuser weiter
wohnt aber jetzt weiß ich würde das ist
weil wir haben zusammen diesem
spielplatz gebaut zum beispiel und das
sind so ganz wichtige momente wo wir
ganz wichtige dinge aufladen heimat ein
begriff den wir an die extreme
verschenkt haben was ist bitte schön an
dem begriff heimat schlecht was ist an
dem begriff stolz schlecht per sie ist
sind das alles keine bösen worte man
muss sie nur aufladen und wenn man leute
machen lässt dann entsteht genau das und
dass es die positive form und wer einmal
erlebt hat dass er mit einer idee in der
diskussion es geschafft hat mit eine
mehrheit zu finden sich durchzusetzen
und das am ende noch gemacht hat der ist
stolz und er wendet sich auch nicht ab
aber herr neu war ich verstehe dass auf
ihrer kommunalen ebene
jetzt haben sie aber gesagt die
demokratie die ist sozusagen der gefahr
zerstört zu werden es gibt genug
zerstörer die das gerne möchten
wie können sie das denn auf der anderen
ebene machen wir haben jetzt über die
kommune gesprochen wir haben vielleicht
noch über sachsen gesprochen aber wie
soll das im bund funktionieren ich kann
ja nur nicht ein bundestag plötzlich
mitbürgern besetzen
dafür habe ich die repräsentative
demokratie dass sie wollen sie das denn
da schaffen
also ich glaube wir müssen erstmal
anfangen zu sortieren wer entscheidet
eigentlich am besten was wir haben in
den letzten jahren und jahrzehnten sehen
wir dass entscheidungen immer weiter
nach oben wandern also von einer kommune
zum kreis von kreis zum landen von
ganzen bund das ist das erste was man
vielleicht mal justieren sollte man
einfach mal coco seite was gehört denn
eigentlich dorthin wo das leben jeden
tag spielt also was das
subsidiaritätsprinzip ist es das haben
wir auch wie vergessen das ist dass das
mal eine gute idee war
da plädiere ich wirklich für weil das
würde erstmal dafür sorgen dass menschen
den demokratie gedanken wieder erleben
können das ist die demokratie werden sie
nur schätzen können wenn sie das selbst
erlebnis haben wenn sie selber gesehen
haben das funktioniert wirklich sonst
kommen sie zu setzen wie die fragen uns
nur alle vier jahre so war soll ich ja
mal ein kreuz machen
da fängt die distanz an wir müssen an
das geht wohl auf der kommunalen ebene
dort wo leute selber wirken können das
wäre der erste schritt
der nächste schritt wäre dass ich mir
wünschen würde dass wir dass wir uns das
parteiensystem mal angucken
uns die frage stellen sollten ob seine
partei tatsächlich als als karriereweg
zu sehen ist oder ob seine partei nicht
vielleicht auch anders organisiert
werden kann beispielsweise durch
amtszeiten begrenzungen also nicht mehr
einen persönlichen ja auch von der
hierarchie in den portalen galerie
bedeutet wenn ich mich möglichst der
meinung anpasse und die chance habe dann
hochzuklettern
er machte eine parteikarriere sind das
die querköpfe selten eher selten
also es ist doch eher dienlich wenn ich
wie in jedem unternehmen wenn ich
karriere machen will
naja das hat mein vater nochmals gesagt
so wende das brot ich ess des lied ich
sing oder so das ist doch logisch und
das ist empathie parteien ich habe nie
gesagt ein können sie ja noch nicht
entkernen ändern
man muss eine andere struktur schaffen
wie soll das denn dann meine ja wie soll
man könnte man könnte ja schon ich meine
die linken machen das ja zu teilen habe
ich jetzt gelernt was den vorsitz
betrifft glaube ich so präsent aber es
ist ja tatsächlich so acht jahre wenn
sie es überhaupt zu langen erschaffen
vorsitzender der linken partei zu
bleiben aber nach acht jahren ist
definitiv schluss
und das sind finde ich ganz wichtige
instrumente die man die man sehen muss
war ja immer zu der struktur die
sichtbar ist und unterbau gehört und
wenn in der sichtbaren struktur wenig
wechsel ist dann haben sie drunter
strukturen die sind dann ewig und das
sehe ich dann beispielsweise auch auf
landesebene innenministerin da sitzen
leute 20 jahre
die machen seit 20 jahren nichts anderes
so die glauben auch irgendwann in jedem
einzelnen fall dass sie alles besser
wissen die glauben dass wirklich also
nur die frage ist ja stimmt das und und
beten die wirklich noch etwas was die
leute tatsächlich brauchen und wollen
und ich finde wenn wir das mal durch
sortieren wert ist sind schon schöner
anfangen und auch eine landtags oder
bundestagsfraktion ist nicht schlecht
beraten wenn sie sich beraten lässt und
warum müssen das immer lobbyisten seien
die im bundestag einen ausgehen warum
können das nicht bürgergeld ist einfach
sagt ich lese jetzt mal gibt es schöne
beispiele international sehr erfolgreich
waren
ich lese jetzt mal ein blogger rat und
der berät zu bestimmten themen eine
fraktion die einen gesetzentwurf
vorbereitet beispielsweise das könnte
man alles machen das wäre in der
rechtlichen situation alles möglich wir
haben jetzt so eine initiative gestartet
die los hand initiative
augustusburg auch machen also werden
jetzt einen drahtlosen zu bestimmten
themen da geht es um zukunftsfragen und
das wäre alles möglich man muss es nur
wollen wir fragen uns alle was haben wir
aus der pandemie gelernt wir haben jetzt
ganz viele punkte angesprochen
lernen wir aus der pandemie auch für die
demokratie etwas in ihrem sinne nicht
nur für die nächste krise die uns da ins
haus stehen wird und da können wir
hundertprozentig sicher sein dass die
kommt sondern auch für die demokratie
und vielleicht für eine andere
gewichtung der kräfteverhältnisse in der
demokratie wie sie suchen
ich fürchte die lerneffekte werden sich
sehr begrenzt halten was ich gelernt
habe da kann ich jetzt wirklich nur für
mich sprechen
ich habe gelernt dass diese gesellschaft
sehr viel zerbrechlicher inzwischen ist
als ich befürchtet habe
und das sage ich mit wirklich also das
sind unterstrichen der sätze in dem fall
weil ich mir wirklich inzwischen sorgen
machen weil wir eine entwicklung haben
die ist gefährlich und wir haben so eine
sehnsucht und wenn sie wenn sie wenn sie
wut haben wenn sie nicht gehört werden
wenn sie vielleicht haben sie mal
versucht sich einzubringen vielleicht
haben sie es gerade erst versucht weil
sie nicht das gefühl haben dass das
gebäude ist wie auch immer sowas wird
irgendwann widerstand das ist so und die
menschen im osten und das ist etwas was
ich im westen in anstrich für mich
spielt das eigentlich keine rolle mehr
aber es ist ja noch mal noch so und da
sind wir auch sehr überschuldet haben
wir viel früher getan dass diese dem
aktions linie immer noch zu sehen ist in
verschiedenen sozialen systeme usw
dass später alles mit ein das ist immer
noch niedrig nun an papa ich muss das
jetzt nicht aufzählen aber die menschen
im osten haben einen epochalen erlebnis
vorsprung
die wissen dass verweigerung system
verändert und das ist etwas das darf man
nicht unterschätzen und genau das steckt
in dem protest auch mit drin
es steckt da drin diese diese 15 minuten
gewissheit wenn ich dort jetzt kreuze
dann schreibt das system auf also dieser
dieser kurze moment gewürgt zu haben das
ist doch ein zeichen für uns das ist
doch leute wollen wirken wollen gewicht
haben wollen gehört werden und das
steckt auch in diesem gut kreuzen drin
weil das passt
dann nämlich ich hoffe trotzdem dass wir
was gelaunt danke schön für das gespräch
danke dass sie behandelt werden danke
[Musik]